قد تبدو هذه مشاهد من فيلم خيال علمي او
ربما داخل احد الورش الصناعيه لكنها ليست
كذلك فهذه غرفه عمليات وهذا الروبوت ذو
الاطراف الاربعه يجري عمليه جراحيه في
غايه التعقيد لانسان حي
[موسيقى]
في سابقه هي الاولى في العالم مستشفى
فالديبرون الجامعي في مدينه برشلونه
باسبانيا يحقق انجازا تاريخيا لزرع رئه
انسان باستخدام الروبوت الروبوت اطلق عليه
سمودا فنشي ويتحكم فيه طبيب جراح عن بعد
وتمت العمليه كالتالي
الجراح قام بعمل شق صغير بطول ثمانيه
سنتيمترات في جسم رجل يبلغ من العمر 65
عاما وازال الرئه المريضه من جسده قبل
ادخال رئه صحيه متبرع بها لتتكلل العمليه
الجراحيه بالنجاح دون مضاعفات صحيه
ان تقنيه الروبوتيه الجديده تمكنت
الجراحين من تجنب اجراء شق كبير كان
فريقنا يفكر في ادخال الجراحه الروبوتيه
في زراعه الرئه وبطبع استخدمناها ونجحت
العمليه وعاد المريض الى المنزل دون الم
سيستخدم الجراحون هذا النهجه مستقبلا
لكن ماذا نعرف عن الجراحه الروبوتيه
الجراحه الروبوتيه والتي تعرف ايضا
بالجراحه بمساعده الروبوتات تقنيه اثارت
ثوره في عالم الطب وتمت اول عمليه
الروبوتيه ناجحه عام
1997 في مدينه كولومبيا البريطانيه بكندا
تتيح هذه التقنيه للاطباء اجراء العديد من
انواع العمليات المعقده بدقه ومرونه وتحكم
اكبر مقارنه باستخدام التقنيات التقليديه
وهذه الروبوتات تتضمن ذراعا مزوده بكاميرا
واذر عن اليه مزوده بادوات جراحيه يتحكم
الجراح في الاذرع بينما يجلس امام لوحه
تحكم متصله بجهاز كمبيوتر بالقرب من طاوله
العمليات التي توفر للجراح مكبرا ثلاثي
الابعاد وعاليه الوضوح لموقع الجراحه
هذه التقنيه لا تتوقف هنا فيمكن للطبيب
عمل الجراحه ايضا عن بعد فتخيل انه يمكن
عمل جراحه لمريض يعيش في الصين والطبيب
الجراح في مستشفى بالهند وهذا المستوى
الجديد من العمليات الجراحيه الروبوتيه تم
تمكينه بواسطه تكنولوجيا الجيل الخامس
التي تسهل عمليه التحكم في الروبوتات بشكل
سلس عن بعد لكن بوجود فريق طبي في غرفه
العمليات
والتاجر تشيكن
الروبوت الجراح او الجراحه الروبوتيه
انتقلت بعالم الطب والعمليات الى مرحله
اخرى واتاحت للجراحين اجراء عمليات جراحيه
معقده بمزيد من التحكم والدقه وبمضاعفات
اقله على المريض وحتى اليوم لا يمكن
للجراحه الروبوتيه ان تحل محل الطبيب
الجراح لكن وعلى غرار قطاعات كثيره اخرى
ازاح فيها الروبوت الانسان عن الواجهه
واخذ مكانه في عمله ومهمته
شاركونا اراءكم هل يحلوا الجراح الروبوت
بشكل كامل محل الطبيب الجراح في المستقبل
[موسيقى]